what is going on Pam I have another
little project for you does it have to
do with these shopping bags filled with
hot dogs
what the hell was that there is a
raccoon in the car White
good morning everybody
who would like an authentic New York
Bagel identity theft is not a joke Jim
Michael you have no idea how high I can
fly
ready go all right first name is Tom no
no no no no dogs no names no rhyming no
sound alike okay you're getting into my
head first name is blank and he goes on
a cruise he goes on a Caribbean cruise I
don't know Katie Holmes no ah but he's
married to her oh Dawson's Creek no no
it has to be a real person Jim come on
okay no no I'm gonna pass I'm gonna pass
uh oh okay
um rhymes with Arnold Schwarzenegger
rhyming
okay another clue another clue okay he's
the governor of California he is The
Terminator those aren't helpful
War goes on forever and Ryan gets
drafted wait
I come from a long line of Fighters my
maternal grandfather was the toughest
guy I ever knew World War II veteran
killed 20 men then spent the rest of the
war in an Allied prison camp
my father
battled blood pressure and obesity all
his life
different kind of fight
hello hello
top of the morning too yeah you pathetic
short little man you don't have any
friends or any family or any land
does anyone smell anything smoky
did you bring your jerky in again
oh my God
fire oh fire oh my goodness what's the
procedure I talk a lot so I've learned
to just tune myself out
so
I'm happy to be here
it's very nice to see all of you they're
all looking well today is a women in the
workplace thing
Jan's coming in from corporate to talk
to all the women about
[Music]
um
I don't really know what but Michael's
not allowed in she said that about five
times women today though we have the
same options as men we often face a very
different set of obstacles in getting
there
hi any messages you're soaking wet oh
well Jim and I got caught in a little
flash rain flash winds flash lightning
wow sounds scary it was it was and then
in an instant it wasn't why isn't Jim
what I outran it here we go make a
U-turn if possible are you okay
foreign
I am Michael Scott I am the captain of
this party I'm Captain Jack I'm captain
of the ship ah I'm also captain of
anyone who sets foot on the ship hi
welcome for it
in an office when you are ranking people
manager is higher than captain
on a boat who knows it's nebulos
watching people get sick always makes me
sick and
frankly so does talking about it so wow
in five minutes this ship is going to be
at the bottom of the lake
and there aren't enough spaces on the
Lifeboat who are we gonna save do we
save sales do we save customer service
do we save accounting this is a business
scenario right it's a scary house
something in each and every one of us
have to think about
aye aye Captain it's like a home movie
yeah if Michael Scott did your whole
movie
it's 11 years okay
this has been my dream for 11 years
and if you don't think it's great then
you're basically saying you don't
believe in my dream it's your dream you
never even mentioned it before we talk
about a lot of things Holly you know I
was eventually going to get around to my
dream obviously
11 years that I could have been working
on the scar nebulous why do you have to
make a movie at all because if I don't
have this what do I
have really you can't think of anything
else that you might have
[Music]
um
this is a white
well if we're complaining a lot of
people think your Elvis voice is
annoying okay who said that I'm just
people for the record
I think it's pretty fantastic well thank
you thank you a lot
[Music]
um
hello everyone I am Michael Scott
deleted immediately
I know
good
all right